[Música]
el presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva visitó el estado de
marañao bajo estado de emergencia por
las lluvias e inundaciones el viaje se
produjo a la víspera de este 10 de Abril
cuando el mandatario cumple sus primeros
100 días en el poder
la presidenta de Honduras Xiomara Castro
anunció lo que calificó de una dura
intervención en las cárceles del país
tras los enfrentamientos registrados en
cuatro centros de reclusión que dejaron
un muerto y siete heridos la mandataria
aseguró que se respetará la humanidad de
los detenidos sus Defensores y
familiares ampliamos desde Tegucigalpa
miles de guatemaltecos participaron en
las tradicionales conmemoraciones y
actos católicos de la Semana Santa con
indumentaria típica hicieron parte de
las procesiones y demás ritos que desde
noviembre de 2022 fueron declarados
patrimonio de la UNESCO Tenemos reporte
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Brasil donde las lluvias e inundaciones
que afectan varias zonas del país han
hecho que el estado demarañado declare
la emergencia en más de medio centenar
de ciudades hasta el sitio llegó el
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva en
lo que va del mes las precipitaciones
han dejado al menos seis personas
muertas en esa localidad la visita de
Lula se sucede en la víspera de sus
primeros 100 días en el poder Rafael
Pérez nos trae los detalles
al cumplir 100 días en el poder Lula
recorre el estado de marañao allí unas
53 ciudades se declararon en emergencia
por las lluvias e inundaciones que
afectaron a unas 36,000 familias el
presidente acompañado por varios de sus
ministros llamó a la unión de los
diferentes sistemas de gobierno
creo que tenemos que cuidar a las
personas que fueron víctimas la gente
pide colchones la gente pide cilindros
de gas
la gente pide cualquier cosa que le
pueda dar cierta comodidad lo que el
gobierno puede hacer
este cruce entre el Gobierno Federal el
gobierno Estatal y gobiernos municipales
es obligatorio
el mandatario brasileño ha hecho de los
programas sociales el centro de la
agenda de sus primeras 14 semanas en el
poder al restaurar subsidios y ayudas
para reducir la pobreza que habían sido
derogados por su antecesor Yahir
bolsonaro la inclusión en su gobierno de
minorías sexuales raciales y étnicas
también estableció un cambio en el trato
a estos grupos y la mujer con respecto a
la administración anterior la gestión
del partido de los trabajadores ha
marcado un punto de giro además en la
protección del medio ambiente con
Especial cuidado en el tema de la
deforestación en la amazonía brasilera
la política exterior de Lula también le
ha otorgado ritmo a su mandato el
regreso a la celac el reintegro a la
unasur la reactivación de relaciones con
Venezuela y los esfuerzos por la paz en
Ucrania han puesto a Brasil nuevamente
en el escenario internacional
en estos primeros meses de gobierno Lula
enfrentó un desafío sin precedentes en
la vida democrática de la nación el
asalto a la sede de los tres poderes en
Brasilia por parte de Los Seguidores del
expresidente bolsonaro lo que le dejó
además el reto de disminuir la
polarización
continuamos en Honduras porque la
presentación maracastro anunció una
intervención dura pero respetuosa de las
cárceles del país tras los
enfrentamientos simultáneos entre
pandillas en cuatro centros
penitenciarios que dejaron un fallecido
y siete heridos la mandataria resaltó
que serán defendidos los derechos
humanos de los detenidos sus familiares
y Defensores al tiempo que afirmó que el
crimen no sólo se combate con el castigo
sino también con la prevención desde
Tegucigalpa Kenia Torres corresponsal de
France 24 nos amplió los detalles
luego de la amotinamiento suscitado de
manera simultánea en cuatro cárceles de
Honduras dos de ellas de máxima
seguridad y que dejó como saldo a un
privado de libertad muerto y a 12
heridos la presidenta de Honduras
Xiomara Castro anunció mano dura y la
intervención de los centros
penitenciarios la mandataria se
manifestó a través de su cuenta oficial
de Twitter escribiendo que la
intervención será dura pero respetuosa
de la humanidad de los encausados sus
familiares y los defensores voy a
intervenir enérgicamente los centros
penales dijo la mandataria por su parte
autoridades del Instituto Nacional
penitenciario confirmaron a France 24
que ya la Policía Nacional había tomado
nuevamente el control de estos centros
de detención Así mismo manifestaron que
el enfrentamiento se había suscitado
entre miembros de la Mara m-13 y la
pandilla 18 todo esto en el marco de la
entrada en vigencia de una intervención
de los centros penitenciarios del país
como parte de la política de seguridad y
defensa puesta en marcha por el gobierno
de la presidenta Castro vamos a
Guatemala donde el 75% de la población
es católica y su semana santa es una de
las más reconocidas en el Continente
miles de personas celebran los diversos
ritos y procesiones que desde noviembre
de 2022 fueron declarados patrimonio de
la UNESCO Andrés Suárez corresponsal de
France 24 nos amplió la información
semana santa de Guatemala trasciende lo
religioso y se vive como una fiesta
nacional son días inagotables con noches
en vela sin duda es la celebración que
genera mayor arraigo y orgullo para los
guatemaltecos con el aliciente de que el
pasado noviembre está la Semana Santa de
Guatemala fue escogida como patrimonio
inmaterial de la humanidad por la UNESCO
es una mezcla de sabores culturas
colores verdad las personas indígenas
También tienen devoción a Jesucristo y a
través de la cultura de ellos lo
demuestran en distintos actos de tipo
religioso también pues en Guatemala
existe mucha devoción creemos mucho en
Dios en la la hay mucho la la religión
católica es la que persiste más sacar la
semana santa de Guatemala se celebran
los 22 departamentos del país con más de
55 cortejos profesionales que conmemoran
la pasión muerte y resurrección de
Jesucristo pero es aquí en antigua donde
se vive la solemnidad y más pintoresco
Entre nubes de incienso la población
Maya marcha sin cesar no no nos cansamos
creo que esto es como le llamamos
nosotros nuestra penitencia cierto
Entonces nosotros andamos aquí hasta el
final de su entrada pues haciendo
nuestra penitencia como no vamos a
sufrir un poco si Nuestro Señor sufrió
mucho más por nosotros estado una semana
santa de Sevilla estado en la semana
santa de Valladolid que son grandes y
sinceramente digo que esta semana santa
de Guatemala de aquí de antigua me ha
impresionado grandemente por el fervor
del pueblo por las alfombras de flores
por tanto contra el amor con el cual
este Ciudad entera se la dedica a Dios
los orígenes de la Semana Santa en
Guatemala se remontan al siglo 16
justamente en esta ciudad antigua aquí
comenzó el sincretismo de la fe católica
que trajeron los españoles con la vasta
cultura de los indígenas Maya una
población que en este país
centroamericano representa el 45% de los
18 millones de habitantes en el estado
estadounidense de tennes y dos
representantes demócratas fueron
expulsados de la cámara de
representantes Estatal controlada Por
los republicanos tras protestar a favor
del control de armas se trata de los
legisladores Justin Jones y Justin
pearson quienes en conjunto con Gloria
Johnson otra representante que se salvó
por un voto de ser expulsada se unieron
a cientos de manifestantes en el
Capitolio Estatal de Nashville para
exigir leyes de armas más estrictas
cuatro días después del tiroteo masivo
en una escuela local su excursión ha
provocado protestas nacionales de
integrantes del partido demócrata
la gran mayoría de la asamblea general
de tennes y encabezada por los
republicanos trató de linchar
políticamente a tres de sus miembros
porque hablamos fuera del lugar en
contra del statu quo del gobierno
después de la trágica muerte de seis
personas en el tiroteo de la escuela
covenant en Nashville cerramos en
Colombia donde se cumplieron 75 años del
asesinato del líder político liberal
Jorge eliécer Gaitán el 9 de abril de
1948 tras el homicidio del Caudillo las
calles de Bogotá la capital se
sumergieron en una espiral de violencia
esas trágicas horas se saltaron con la
intervención del ejército y dejaron Por
lo menos 550 muertos según los
periódicos de la época cifra que
investigadores elevan a más de 2000 el
episodio conocido como El bogotazo marcó
una antes y un después en la historia
del país la imagen de Gaitán trascendió
el tiempo y durante varios años estuvo
presente en el billete de mil pesos
colombianos
Así finalizamos esta informativo gracias
por su sintonía
[Música]